day and night firefighters are
struggling to combat forest and
bushfires in South Central Chile a
stifling Heat Wave and strong winds are
driving Flames North and South
destroying thousands of homes schools
and crops this isn't the first time for
Enrique narves
the wildfires in 2011 burnt my house all
my trees everything I was left with my
arms crossed and now I don't want to go
through the same again that is why I'm
here in case something happens
so far there's been at least 24
confirmed deaths scores are missing
which is why the government is warning
people to heat evacuation notices
immediately
active files can advance 27 kilometers
an hour and people can't escape on foot
fast enough when the fire arrives it's
impossible to save their lives if they
don't evacuate in an opportune fashion
worse yet many people live in remote
areas where Mobile phone coverage has
been interrupted and where firefighters
can't reach them to warn them to leave
before it's too late
Chili's calls for help are being met
overnight a team of Colombian
firefighters specializing in forest
fires arrived to join hundreds from
Mexico Spain and Brazil
but the fires are still spreading out of
control sending smoke in all directions
which you would normally see here is a
bright summer's day but the winds are
pushing the smoke from South Central
Chile north towards the capital Santiago
authorities are warning people not to
exercise outdoors and to keep their
windows closed to prevent the smoke and
Ash from getting in their homes
people who have lost their homes to the
fire are asking authorities to declare a
night curfew to prevent thieves from
taking the little they have left for
rebuilding
so far the Flames have not reached towns
or cities but the fear is that the fires
could spread quickly to densely
populated areas
where the destruction would be
incalculable
you see a Newman Al Jazeera Santiago